es ist 1:20 Uhr mittwoch der 21 August
2013 es sind 10 die aus einer Apokalypse
für eine wir warten auf von dem Geschrei
Angriff mit Chemiewaffen Chemiewaffen
Chemiewaffen die Menschen schrien auf
den Straßen kommt runter an da riefen
bleibt im Haus schließt die Fenster
die Stadt gute in der Nähe von Damaskus
wird an diesem Morgen zum Ziel eines der
ringgas Angriffs das ist ein Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit in dieser Nacht
werden bis zu 1.800 Menschen sterben die
genaue Todeszahl ist bis heute nicht
geklärt
zuerst hatte ich Angst weil ich nichts
wusste was ich tun soll ich war
aufgeregt konnte mich nicht
konzentrieren nicht denken ich wusste
nicht was ich tun sollte um meine
schwangere Frau meine Kinder meine
Eltern zu schützen ich wusste nicht was
Folgen werden ich musste ruhig bleiben
und die Tour fest verschließen
[Musik]
bringt seine Familie ins Badezimmer die
Ritzen der Tür verstopft er mit nassen
Handtüchern so hofft er bleibt der
Kampfstoff draußen ein Trugschluss wie
sie später herausstellen wird Stunden
später da dämmert es schon verlässt er
erstmals alleine die Wohnung geht auf
die Straße
es gibt keine Worte um die Situation zu
beschreiben die Einlagen tut da die
anderen nahmen den letzten Atemzug
ich erinnere eine Familie sie saß am
Abend ruhig im Hof ihres Hauses sie
waren alle tot ich kann das nicht
beschreiben
die Notaufnahme voller Menschen dr Eimer
hat in dieser Nachtdienst
[Musik]
einen Patienten fragte ich wo sind deine
Angehörigen aber er bettelte mich nur an
er bettelte um Sauerstoff er bettelte
dass ich ihm helfen sollte zu überleben
mehr wollte er nicht ich werde das nie
vergessen es gab einfach keinen
Sauerstoff mehr das soll ringgas war
überall und tötete die Menschen
als abomalik der Familienvater der seine
Liebsten schützen wollte zurückkehrt und
seine Wohnung da haben selbst die
schwangere Frau und die Kinder Schaum
vor dem Mund
seine Tochter rital wird nur wenige
Monate nach dem Angriff geboren mit
einer Behinderung eine mögliche
Spätfolge
[Musik]
als sie geboren wurde sagten die Ärzte
sie hat unter Sauerstoffmangel gelitten
sie fragten mich wo habt ihr gelebt ich
sagte ihnen dort wo sie mit sarinas
bombardiert haben
von dem Mann dem die Weltgemeinschaft
vorwirft höchstwahrscheinlich hinter den
Angriffen zu stecken Bascha Allahs hat
syriens Machthaber
seit zehn Jahren fördern wir dass die
internationale Gemeinschaft dieses
mörderische ihn verurteilt wieso darf
dieser kriminelle frei rumlaufen ohne
bestraft zu werden
[Musik]
kann nicht vergessen
bis heute zehn Jahre später heilen
unserer Wunden nicht denn es gibt keine
Gerechtigkeit
[Musik]
der Arzt aus guter lebt heute im
Nordwesten Syriens in der Region die
nicht von Assads Regime kontrolliert
wird viele seiner Patienten haben guter
überlebt heute leiden sie an
Mangelernährung dazu kommen immer mehr
Cholera Fälle durch verunreinigtes
Trinkwasser medizinische Hilfe gibt es
hier kaum doch dazu später mehr ich
warne vor einer massiven humanitären
Katastrophe denn 70 bis 80% der
Bevölkerung hier leben unter der
Armutsgrenze
so wie abomalik und seine Familie sie
haben ein tagesauskommen der Bauer hat
sich Setzlinge aus der alten Heimat
mitgebracht spezielle Gemüsesorten die
er damals in guter angebaut hat davon
lebt die Familie eigentlich sollten Sie
von den Hilfslieferungen der Vereinten
Nationen profitieren aber die kommen
hier nicht an
Nummer Fehler hier kommt keine Hilfe an
hier ist nichts niemand kümmert sich
[Musik]
Abu Malek fährt mit uns in Richtung der
Grenzübergänge einer der bekanntesten
ist BAB alhauer seit dem verheerenden
Beben vom Februar war der Übergang
geöffnet doch russland hat mit seinem
Veto im UN-Sicherheitsrat immer wieder
dafür gesorgt dass die Hilfslieferungen
gestoppt werden nun gibt es eine neue
Einigung die Grenzübergänge bleiben
offen unter der Bedingung dass die
Verteilung über Damaskus gesteuert wird
von Organisationen wie dem syrischen
Roten Halbmond was das bedeutet weiß
dieser Mann nur zu gut Rabia hat für sie
gearbeitet er berichtet von einem
betrügerischen System
das ist die Liste hier die registrierten
Flüchtlinge die nicht in den staatlich
kontrollierten gebeten leben hier die
Anzahl der Hilfsgüter hier wird
abgefragt sind die Hilfen die
ausgeliefert wurden ordentlich
dokumentiert
die Antwort hier ist ja aber das stimmt
nicht
während meiner Arbeit haben wir von der
Sicherheitsabteilung immer wieder den
Befehl erhalten Ihnen helfen zu schicken
ohne dass das dokumentiert wird
schon vor zehn Jahren sei es gängig
gewesen sagt Rabia dass die Hilfen von
Soldaten des Regimes und Checkpoints
regelrecht geplündert worden er rechnet
nicht damit dass sich das nun ändert im
Gegenteil
bis jetzt gibt es keine Beweise davor
dass irgendeine Hilfe in Nordwest Syrien
angekommen ist
am Grenzübergang
die letzten Hilfslieferungen an
der letzte unkonvoi mit hillsgütern der
den Grenzübergang Babel Hauer passierte
kam am 9 juli es war ein 79 LKW voll mit
verschiedensten Materialien die
Hilfslieferungen der Vereinten Nationen
sind seit 40 Tagen nicht eingetroffen
unterdessen hunderte Kilometer im
Landesinneren Assad Damaskus wir sind
unterwegs mit einer versteckten Kamera
auf den Märkten der Hauptstadt ein rara
Einblick diese Bilder beweisen das was
die Vereinten Nation wohl am meisten
fürchten dürften und fast jeder hier
weiß davon nur offen reden können sie
nicht
[Musik]
die Regierung stiehlt die Hilfe
kaufen Sie in einem Einkaufsladen es
gibt aber auch einen ganzen Markt für
Hilfsgüter sie verkaufen dort Reis
Zucker Öl Konserven
auch wir werden fündig weiße Bohnen aus
der us aus der amerikanischen
Hilfslieferung
ist das aus der Hilfslieferung ja das
Kilo wird hierfür umgerechnet zwei Euro
angeboten
Sonnenblumenöl vom
Welternährungsprogramm der Vereinten
Nationen mit der Inschrift nicht für den
Verkauf bestimmt
Reis aus Indien
ist das Reis aus der Hilfe ja und dann
hunderte Päckchen Notnahrung für
mangelernährte Kinder vom
Welternährungsprogramm der Vereinten
Nation
ist das auch aus der Hilfe
das Päckchen im Angebot für umgerechnet
15 bis 30 Cent ein systematischer
Missbrauch mit Hilfslieferung
es ist Nahrung die in den Camps im
Nordwesten so bitter nötig wäre
ich gebe Ihnen
Blanka hohensalders findet Väter ihm das
ausgerechnet der Mann der Krieg gegen
sie führt nun die Kontrolle habe über
ihre Hilfsgüter sondern praktischer
drei Monate sind es jetzt ohne Hilfen
meine Kinder kommen von der Arbeit und
wollen etwas Süßes zumindest Tee aber
ich habe keinen Zucker ich sage Ihnen es
gibt keinen Zucker ich muss mir Geld
leihen um ein halbes Kilo Zucker zu
kaufen
ein Gaskocher habe Väter ihm seit fünf
Jahren nicht mehr benutzt seitdem sie
ihr Haus verlassen mussten zu zwölf
leben sie nun hier weil auch
brennholzmangel Ware ist wird der Tee
auf verbrannten Plastik gekocht
ich schicke die Kinder zu den Müllhalden
damit sie nach Plastik suchen so kann
ich ein Feuer anmachen für sie kochen
ich habe kein Gas darum verbrenne ich
die Plastikflaschen und koche den Tee
dann auf dem Ofen
nicht nur das Essen ist ein Problem
mein Name ist radicha jeden Tag leere
ich das Abwasser in den Abwasserkanal es
stinkt und dort sind Krankheiten drin
ich lehre das Loch und bringe es in den
Abwasserkanal
Toilette und Dusche sind im Zelt jeden
Tag muss radiecher das Abwasser abtragen
das gesamte Camp ist umsound von
stinkendem Abwasser hier lassen die
Bauern der Umgebung ihr viehtrinken
seit dem Herbst vergangenes Jahr häufen
sich im Nordwesten Syriens die Cholera
Fälle
Ärzte waren vor einer humanitären
Katastrophe der Grund
verunreinigtes Trinkwasser
zu elf lebt diese Familie hier seit vier
Jahren die Kinder gehen arbeiten für
umgerechnet 17 Cent das reiche hinten
und vorne nicht Hitze und Hunger doch
das Schlimmste sei das dreckige
Wasserkanal macht uns am meisten zu
schaffen er stinkt eklig es machte
Kinder krank für zu allergischer
Bronchitis und Infektionskrankheiten
mein Bruder und meine Nichte sie hatten
sich infiziert ihr ganzer Körper war
voll mit kleinen Beulen sie litten sehr
und müssten oft behandelt werden weil es
kommt umgeht er zeigt uns den Wassertank
hat fünf Fass erreicht meistens nur für
einen halben Tag
und wofür benutzt du dieses Wasser
zum Waschen zum Duschen zum Abwasch zum
Kochen und natürlich als Trinkwasser
natürlich wir sehen uns dazu gezwungen
was sollen wir machen
es ist eine Kindheit in der Not doch es
gibt sie die wenigen unbeschwerten
Momente in der Woche immer wieder
schicken Menschen aus der Gegend
pumpwagen voller Wasser auch das war
unreinigt aber so bleibt zumindest eine
Abkühlung Spaß der bitter nötig ist
morgens um 7:30 Uhr hat es hier schon 43
Grad ein nasses Tuch auf dem Kopf anders
ist es drin und erträglich
die letzten zwei drei Tage war die
Temperatur draußen bei 43 44 Grad im
Zelten war es 50 es ist unerträglich
so sieht sie hier im Sommer aus im
Winter es ist noch viel schlimmer
die Kinder ausgezehrt die erwachsen
en seine Frau gehe arbeiten
auch ihr verdienstreiche maximal für
vier Tüten Brot am Tag bei Alf Kindern
reicht das nicht das Assad nun die Hand
auf der Hilfe habe die ihr Überleben
sichern soll ist für die meisten hier
unverständlich
sie wollen die Hilfe schicken durch das
Regime also durch den Mann der uns
obdachlos gemacht hat der so viele von
uns ermordet hat der uns mit
Chemiewaffen bombardiert hat tausende
wurden in guter in kansische Kuhn und
anderen Gegenden umgebracht
unser Interview nutzt der Mann als
verzweifelten Appell an den Westen wir
möchten den Vereinten Nationen sagen
dass wenn die Hilfen über das Regime
kommt dann werden sie nicht ankommen
fest steht Ärzte und Hilfsorganisationen
warnen vor einer weiteren humanitären
Krise in dem Land das seit 12 Jahren im
Bürgerkrieg lebt eine Krise die nun
durch die neue internationale
Vereinbarung die Hilfen über Assads
Regime zu koordinieren massiv verschärft
werden dürfte
[Musik]